Guys sometimes a play is so epic,
so perfectly timed, so clutch,
that it lives on forever in League of Legends, as an iconic moment.
Unfortunately the same can also be said for the worst of the worst misplays.
So from bad Baron plays that lost the game,
to the most infamous ult that never happened, here are the Top 10 Misplays in League of Legends.
To  kick off our list of fails we’ve got one
that’s so well known it’s become a meme.
In what has since become known as “pulling a Dyrus” we have what might be one of the
funniest images in League history.
As the casters and the camera are focused on the early game mid lane matchup they’re
interrupted abruptly:
(Casting)
He pulled a Dyrus.
He died farming wolves 8 and a half minutes into the game.
The Flash Summoner spell is undoubtedly the
most important and powerful in League of Legends.
And when a Flash goes wrong, it goes really wrong.
Coming in at number 9 xPeke shows us just how bad a Flash can be.
He blinks over the wall directly in the middle of the team fight and his health bar
melts on site.
(Casting)
He tried to play Sivir like a midlane mage.
Not a lot of burst damage there.
At number 8 Doublelift shows us that even the best in the world need to ease
their way back into competitive play sometimes.
After a tough team fight where Team Liquid had their backs against the wall, Doublelift
and the surviving members of TL looked to regroup and farm-up.
Double rotates to the red buff and gets ready for the possibility of another fight.
Little did he know that the real fight was right in front of him.
a he dies embarrassingly to the cold claws of the Red brambleback.
(Casting)
Nothing brings you back to earth quite like being punked out by an NPC in front of tens
of thousands of people.
At number seven we’ve got what can only be described as a swing … and a miss.
If you’ve ever played League you’re definitely familiar with just how game breaking a strong
Annie's ultimate can be.
That is, if you actually can hit your opponents with it..
Unfortunately KiWi Kid was unable to land his ult after flashing forward and unleashed
Tibbers into … well … nobody.
(Casting)
When it comes to throwing games in the North American LCS, perhaps noone is as noteworthy
as Coast.
They’re the champions of giving it all away.
And here, is maybe the greatest example of just that.
Coast held a small lead over Dignitas until their mid laner Jesiz got caught out — to
which they responded by trying to force Baron.
At number six we've got one of the stranger calls you're ever likely to see, Dig was
able to counter by simply walking their team down the mid lane and destroying Coast’s nexus.
(Casting)
Vision control is arguably the single most
important thing in League of Legends.
Whichever team has eyes on the majority of the map, is often the one with a lead.
Here we see a hilarious example of this.
Samsung all pile into a bush looking to catch Najin off-guard and land a pick.
Little do they know, Najin has vision on that
bush.
(Casting)
At number four we’ve got the Flash, or lack there of, heard round the League of Legends
community.
We all know that at the centre of any good League meme is usually a hilarious
misplay.
And maybe no pro player meme is as ubiquitous as Doublelift’s flash still being up.
Here’s where it all started, at World’s in 2017 his team is wrapped up in a brutal
team fight against Misfits.
And then double dies,
With that damn flash, sitting there simply unused.
(Casting)
"I get f*cked right here and I 100% agree,
this is a situation where I should have flashed,
100% I don't need to get hit by chain or the flash from Dragus. I didn't react in time."
When you queue into a game of League of Legends, you’re expecting a five versus five match.
An even affair that will inevitably determine a winner.
But sometimes that opposing turret feels like the 6th-man that you never thought to worry
about.
And other times, the opposing teams makes you feel a little bit better by getting double
killed by the rift herald.
At number three we’ve got maybe the funniest clip out there — two NPC’s getting the
better of four pro League of Legends players.
(Casting)
The runner-up on our list comes from the 2017 League of Legends World Championship.
North America had high hopes for Immortals at Worlds 2017, but after posting a middling
2-2 group stage record, looked to get back on track against an 0-4 Fnatic squad.
As Fnatic started to turn the tide of a key late game team fight.
Immortals star Cody Sun, tried to make a big play to  clutch it out.
But it was more than a little awkward.
(Casting)
Of all the misplays on this list, this one may have been the most costly.
TSM and Cloud9 were facing off in Game 5 of the NA LCS finals and the two rivals were
neck and neck when the game’s pivotal teamfight broke out..
In what is maybe the most memorable ULT that never happened, Jensen just never Chronobreaks
in this team fight and TSM are able to capitalize
and win the title.
Taking the top spot on our list is that most impactful ultimate that never happened.
(Casting)
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.